I'm not pause on offense to anyone who
else in this belief book when I actually
looked it properly I thought hang on why
would God have to send he's only
begotten Son
down on earth to be rejected tortured
killed so he would then forgive my sin
if I accept him for that and I used to
ask God for the truth yeah so I was
telling about Christianity so you guys
are doing Jesus was a messenger and not
just schmuck to me cuz I knew I was a
Christian Jesus was a messenger but I
got confused you know was he God the
messenger all think like do you believe
Jesus was literally a God that he was
walking earth and he was God Almighty
he's in that future - no he wasn't he
was you know I mean when you say when it
was he sent by God yes we've got we've
got they've got my new I love in their
book no way for cuz cuz God God is not
like on him to his creation I'm gonna
found that my team is the second most
mentioned prophet in the Quran that's
when I thought look what about he was
sent to die for your sins how did you
struggle with that why did he look up to
the heavens and say Lord or Father why
has thou forsaken me it just doesn't
sound like a lot of so much lemmya lead
well immunity well let me uh one ahead
God doesn't have skin color zip code
birthdate death date I mean people these
busy busy busy busy they're not they're
not look but the life is taking them
away from thinking and contemplating
about the failure everything has a
purpose in life everything I said that's
just a phone I said look at the planets
the earth disposed the moon song to
human elijah be lit up a couple hikmah t
there is no room for terrorism in Islam
no losses in the Connie weather kills an
innocent person is lamb is this Islam is
that we hear all of the nonsense all the
gibberish what advice do you have for
that when you look into it if you're
gonna listen to the media if you're
gonna listen to Facebook if you're gonna
listen to your friends then
it's your own fault for having them
kinda falls because it's not true about
they have some lunch here on the floor
very nice cozy beautiful huh lemony food
that's nice to see it's time to pray
just drop the rug and making that
prostration gratefulness the key to
happiness to create a happiness is gray
fun is showing gratitude by taking a
time out and thinking the Creator the
one creator one guy all the blessings of
the mountains
[Music]
Salam alaikum guys have a nice look very
comfortable Yemeni restaurant and you
know you usually hear the Jehovah's
Witnesses there on the bikes we found a
Muslim on a bike given dower Abdullah
Salam alaikum brother so what's this
what's this bike so the situation about
huh I use a lot riding my bike well
alongside things just give out leaflets
share sharing the purpose of life of
people on the bike no now you weren't
you weren't always Muslim huh no no I
was a Christian you were a Christian
yeah were you riding the bike back then
no no so you really I mean you figured
out the purpose of life you started
living it and now you realize the
obligation on every Muslim to share the
message because if you really care
you're gonna share and you were that
excited and motivated to get out there
to share the purpose of life with people
yeah yeah that's the truth and you know
when you know and you know what you
don't know yeah so you just want to
spread it don't ya so what was it now
about Islam coming up were you a
practicing Christian or so so Christian
was a social no no Harry go home well I
was a Christian but I only become a
Mormon and I used to ask God for the
truth
yeah and then something very bad
happened that I didn't do it was accused
for me I went somewhere and then I just
told about Islam by a basically an armed
robber Wow so I was charged something
about Christianity so yeah you guys are
doing supposed to be doing yeah and he's
telling you about Islam yeah
telling them about Christianity yeah
while you're doing something then he
told me about the one God
not the only believe in the one god
jesus was a messenger and not just
schmuck to me because I knew was the
Christian Jesus was a messenger but I
got confused you know was he God the
messenger or you know wow that's
powerful man in the seat see people like
you because we usually ask people we say
Christians do you believe and they don't
think like do you believe Jesus was
literally a God that he was walking
earth and he was God Almighty he's in
that picture - no he wasn't he was you
know I mean when you say when he was he
sent by God definitely yes sent Michaels
I'm gonna found out that he was the
second most mentioned prophet in the
Koran that's when I thought we've got
we've got we've got my realize that the
Jews they rejected prophets and the
Christians they rejected Mohammed the
Muslims they accepted them all yeah so
when I looked into what they preach and
what we taught for this is definitely
you know there's no way for cuz cuz God
God is not like on to his creation he's
nothing like unto his creation what
about they said no okay we believe he's
sent and we believe that means that he
was the messengers like Abraham Moses
and all the preceding messenger they
came the same message Islam submit your
will to the Creator not the creation but
if someone says now look what about he
was sent to die for your sins how did
you struggle with that did you believe
that he never he never yeah but what
Jesus never told me that he was coming
here to die for my sin there he never
told he never ever told anybody English
I mean okay for example when they caught
him which they didn't catch and he
thought well he might have done and they
caught him at the end and they was gonna
put him on the cross yeah
how come he didn't tell us before that
why didn't he tell us all I'm gonna die
on the cross for your sins he didn't why
did he look up to the heavens and say
Lord or Father why has thou forsaken me
it just doesn't sound like
somebody that was son to say he died on
the cross for my and then I thought my
rock no I'm not causing offence to
anyone who else's belief but when I
actually looked it properly I thought
hang on why would God cut the send he's
only begotten son down on earth to be
rejected tortured killed so he would
then forgive my sin if I accept him for
that I don't they just doesn't what
about here in Islam we have the pure
monotheism just worshiping the crater
all that makes sense verse Trinity who
Allah who I had a lot of so mottley
merely dwell immunity well let me have
one ahead which is sort of a class
sincerity you know that that tells us
about God's oneness and you cannot be
confused about where he says he is one
there was nothing like unto him he
begets not nor was he begotten and then
he's nothing compelling comparison to
him that is how he that is the oneness
of God God doesn't have skin colors zip
code birthdate death date I mean people
say that God created man in His image
which is no true if you look at a clock
clock clock has got a hand isn't it but
it's not like mine in your hand yeah
he's a God he's nothing he's nothing
like laser committee Sheikh there's
nothing nothing you cannot compare
anything he says however you imagine me
to be
I'm far from that much yeah but we get
to know as both attributes the loving
the kind of the merciful is up but he's
absolutely one and last and in closing
so that made sense so that verses the
Trinity many people struggle with that
it doesn't make sense but that makes
sense a kid can understand just just one
God one God he sent those messengers
same message submit your will to the
Creator what had you really thinking
about purpose like to really motivate
people because people are not they're
here and they're just going through life
but they're not thinking like how did I
get here why am I here where am I going
because the soul rushed in his life
everybody's busy busy busy busy they're
not they're not that but the life is
taking them away from thinking and
contemplating about the failure where I
was I have 23 hours
to contemplate on it you know so when
when when and I asked my I say to people
look into you know because it's not it's
not a joke and death is upon was wonder
you know yeah one thing that we can all
be guaranteed there's no I mean
everything has a purpose in life
everything I mean you can't show me
anything in this room that doesn't have
a purpose you spoon this has a purpose
by headphones other purpose you know
it's like my mind father said to me that
you didn't believe in God and that he
said that you think they still claim of
a Big Bang so I've seen something on a
dolly see anything and I said ok no so I
put my phone on the table now I think of
a phone it's just a fine I said if I
told you that just came here on its own
and not being crazy would you believe I
said that's just a phone I said look at
the planets the earth disposed the moon
song the human eyes can't we can't even
for the people out there who they hear
about it snob this opinion that opinion
islam is this Islam is that we hear all
of the nonsense all the gibberish what
advice do you have for them [ __ ] for
the people who are out there they hear
Islam's about terrorism love oppressing
women Islam's discourse on is that
they're forming opinions baseless
opinions off the media another what
advice do you have for them if you
actually go and look into Islam properly
and look at what we believe about these
things you know there is no room in to
terrorism in Islamic no losses in the
crown whoever kills an innocent person
for not just cause or reason I will
judge that person on the Judgment Day as
if he killed the whole of mankind
that's for one innocent life you know
it's long you know is a beautiful
religion but it can only be seen as a
beautiful religion when you look into it
if you're gonna listen to the media if
you're gonna listen to Facebook if
you're gonna listen to your friends then
you know it's your own fault for having
them kinda falls because it's not true
but you can only see they're not true
when you study it I mean that Islam
Islam gave women rights Mock the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu I mean he gave
women wrong
you know the women time when muhammad
sallahu son came the women didn't have
any rights they didn't have any rights
he gave them those three share of you
know when you when someone dies to share
the money you get the dowry on the mom
it's all time everything it's yes so
thank you for sharing there with us
hopefully this could be a motivated
motivation for people who don't know
purpose to seek purpose maybe you like
some of the things if you're sincere
about the oneness of God and the purpose
of life it's there and the Muslims
especially now those who have been
saying we're Muslim you've submitted
your will to the crater look at this
brother Abdullah he accepting he is
taking up the call look at that o de la
subida applicable hikmah t and by all to
the way of your Lord are you doing it
he's doing it come on okay let's get
motivated and shared this message
because if you care you will share the
purpose of life with your brothers and
sisters in Manatee thank you my brother
for ya